it is a big story according to the New
York Times president Trump treats each
day of his presidency as if it were a
television show now that sound
believable to you completely believable
first of all I mean remember when have
you seen a president who will say things
like I may have taped my conversations
with Jim Comey I'll let you know in a
few weeks
he's literally teasing to the next
episode yeah it's hilarious video I'm
down to two candidates for the chairman
of the Fed both very good I'll let you
know what you wanna hear some clips from
next week oh yes dinner with Mitt Romney
and dangles the Secretary of State rip
in front of him and then withdraws and
you know it's it's all done like that a
look at some level if that's his if
that's his metric he's winning he's
dominating the news cycle like nobody
I've ever seen and he he can't stand it
if it's if even one day goes where he's
not doing dinner we do a show and
sometimes we tape sometimes we go live
so we're always trying to figure out
when his the news settle down and with
Obama it was easy you know you just was
so disciplined you know you knew Friday
morning everything was done locked in
with Trump every time we planned the
show one more tweet one you know and if
it's a slow news day or snow Diaz week
you can feel almost feel the the anxiety
building for him and something he's had
to do something odd aback in the news
he's got to do something yeah he just
you know turtles are illegal you know
and it's just he treats it right what
happened and then you know it all gets
no no no that was he didn't really mean
that but you're right he can't stand I
think this current generation people
that are you know very young think that
this is probably the amount of attention
that every president gets every day they
don't know that yeah there's a president
and sometimes you'd go two weeks at a
time and not hear much about that's
exactly right I think Trump in a ways of
redefining the presidency as this kind
of continuous media operation where
often not there isn't much happening or
being done substantively but you're
constantly dominating the media
attention yeah I mean I'm not sure it's
good because
the truth is as president you could
always get news I mean you can start a
war you'll get a lot of news right you
you don't the point is to get things
done not to dominate the media cycle
you're the most famous man in the world
anyway right right
you